then Tendo was once the market dominated
with their popular first party game
purging from oil to smash their consoles
were always one of the best-selling but
after the success of the week they were
not able to launch another successful
product and their stock prices plummeted
however after the recent switch they
have been on rapid rise the heart of the
switch to Nintendo's fate major stick
around till the end to find out
[Music]
welcome to hobbies so I'm Scott Eastern
ruffed Nintendo's first console because
that's already a really long story if
you guys want me to cover the first
hunter is a Nintendo make sure come that
down below the whole journey started
with the NES or Nintendo Entertainment
System with kima in 1985 in North
America the system had already come out
in Japan queers
but there was very little optimism that
it would also do well in the US this is
because this release was right after
1983 video game crash in which the
market was oversaturated with
low-quality crushed games even the US
CEO was very concerned and as a result
they started off with a soft launch in
New York in 1985 and launched nationwide
in 1986 but it quickly caught on as I
came with 17 excellent games this system
introduced Mario Zelda and smashed and
millions of new players and these have
been enduring classics ever since this
console was on the expensive side
costing about $200 then which is about
$475 now so this definitely stifled the
reach of the console but nonetheless
this one of the most iconic consoles of
all time selling sixty-two million units
interiors lifetime and soon after this
until launched a Game Boy which was an
annual device which is much cheaper at
ninety dollars in 1989 this came with
the iconic games Tetris and Super Mario
Land this system was met with intense
competition from the target links and
Sega Game Gear those actually had better
hardware but the Gameboy had better game
titles and there's a company with the
momentum from the NES really made it a
successful product they would go on to
sell 119 million units of the Game Boy
and this along with the any
we'll really put Nintendo on the map for
the u.s. video game market and they
weren't stopping right there in 1991
that came out with the SNES for the same
price there was strong competition from
the Sega Mega drive/genesis but in the
end SNES came out on top they said some
of their most iconic titles including
Super Metroid Yoshi's Island earthbound
Super Mario World and Final Fantasy 6 in
the end they were able to come out with
49 million sales well this wasn't as
good as to any yes it definitely was a
great step and in 1995 it came out with
a Virtual Boy which is one of the worst
parts of all time and didn't even reach
1 million sales which he only 770,000 it
was supposed to be a virtual reality
type of device but it was way too
compromised and underdeveloped it wasn't
even enough first party games to go
along with it I'm not too sure about the
purpose the device either what is it a
successor to the SNES what was a story a
completely new lineup but at this point
they already had the n64 plan which came
out the following year the Virtual Boy
was a really weird step from Nintendo
but since they had the n64 it came out
to next year in 1996 for $200 I was able
to cover up this issue and the n64 was a
revolutionary release at the time and I
came with Super Mario 64 in pilotwings
64 the 3d renderings in these games were
the first of its kind and it really
allowed people also the controller
introduced analog controls to the world
but just because it was a great console
with great games didn't mean they had
performed exceptionally well with your
severe competition from ps2 Nintendo
significantly software here as they
chose not to support game discs like all
their competitors and this we lost on
third-party support from which they
never really recovered you got 33
million sales on the n64 which is marked
by the ps2 s
150 million plus sales but this is still
respectable and just enough to keep them
a significant player in the video game
market in March of 2001
they came out with the Game Boy Advance
we just wanted an tendo's most
conservative launches of all time but
this wasn't necessarily a bad thing
there's a simple great design that sir
is a replacement for the Game Boy it was
backwards compatible and they had a
great game itself building on Nintendo's
- the repertoire there are Super Mario
vents and Tony Hawk's Pro Skater - it's
spectacular but it was all just normal
there was a problem didn't screens
however and a lot of people did complain
as from watering the Game Boy advances
but other than that it was a great
option over a 12-year old Asian Game Boy
it wasn't that innovative or anything
but a hit in the right spot at the right
time and as a result they got really
great sales of 81 million in September
of 2001 they came out with the Gamecube
and this had really strong launch titles
including Luigi's Mansion Super Monkey
Ball waverace Star Wars rogue leader and
assume Super Mario Sunshine but this
came out during a time when the ps2 was
well established in a purple GameCube
simply looked like the kiddie option and
a stool used cartridges which all
results in really back hardware sales of
only 22 million this is a really good
device and had really good games but if
simply could not excel due to time
period that was released and the lack of
cd-rom but despite this the game to make
sure that Nintendo was still out there
in the video game market for right after
that they would come out with the best
product they have ever launched in
November of 2004 which was the DS at
first this devices actually met with a
lot of criticism most people simply did
not understand why you needed two
screens or touch implementation and as a
result was often ridiculed but after a
year and several iconic game releases
including New Super Mario Bros Animal
Crossing wild world and Pokemon Diamond
and Pearl
the D s play started catching on and
plus this is the first into the device
that you can use to play over Wi-Fi
this device is marketed to a completely
new audience and older audience who
wouldn't actually conserve playing games
on traditional home console this new
demographic new games online capability
along with backwards compatibility
really means it
yes unstoppable they reached over 154
million sales with over 140 Diaz games
reaching over 1 million sales each what
started off as a skeptical launch turned
out to be the biggest success of all
time for Nintendo and is a great went on
and success carried on shall we
which came on November of 2006 again
this meant with a lot of criticism once
we put thought was a silly name with a
stupid TV style controller it was a very
odd release from Nintendo it came in at
$250 and included a game and it finally
ditched the cartridges for cd-rom if
launched with Zelda Twilight Princess
and Wii Sports which most avid gamers
dismissed as simplistic but the Western
world considered it a marvel and it was
very popular with families and it came
with a great launches influency with
mario bros super are galaxies Mario Kart
and of course Super Smash Bros which
were all very very popular and the
motion sensors were implemented so well
with Nintendo games and many people
loved it but the motion sensors were
often really bad that came to third
party games but Nintendo would not feel
the effects of this on the Wii in their
across over 100 million sales and with
that the de escena we really helped them
to dominate the gaming market in the
early 2000s and then the 3ds came out in
February of 2011 and it was nothing
revolutionary it was literally ODS with
the 3d gimmick but the 3d gimmick was
very popular at the time it came out
with some nice first part of games italy
mario kart in Super Mario 3d Land but
the third cry support was lackluster
which included asphalt 3d and Super
Monkey Ball 3d but despite this bad
selection of games the mental runaway
nds along with the 3d gimmick really
made the 3ds very powerful but
originally the price was outrageous at
$250 which put it in the price range of
home consoles but this was quickly
reduced to $170 it was much more
acceptable
this price most people thought of as it
could purchase as a replace their Diaz
from 2004 and plus the 3d s was
backwards compatible the 3ds really
succeeded as a good replacement for the
DS and today they have over seventy
million sales on the 3GS the 3ds is like
the opposite of the Gamecube it wasn't
that good of a device and didn't have
that good games but it sold well
nonetheless and then there was a Wii U
and we all know that it did really
really bad but here are the top reasons
why they weren't labeled sound out well
first of all the controllers were really
confusing there's a gamepad that we
remotes and that Wii U pro controller
and in a lot of games even first party
games like splatoon you couldn't even
use the Wii U pro controller or Wii
Remote
you had to use the gamepad and the Wii U
was very underpowered it was not a level
of the ps3 and xbox360
he should be completely obliterated by
the Xbox one and ps4 and of course yeah
terrible third-party support is very
underpowered and couldn't even run a lot
of the games at the ps4 Xbox one could
run and so third bright publishers had
to water down their games and after
we've got bad sales publishers simply
did not want to publish more games for
the Wii U and it basically had no
internal storage and a measly 16
gigabytes on the base version and an
awesome
32 gigabytes on the deluxe version this
wasn't even comparable to the 500
gigabytes and 1 terabyte hard drives and
the ps4 and Xbox one and the Wii U was
very expensive for what it was the base
model was three million dollars then the
flux model was $350 the Xbox one and ps4
were much more powerful for the same
price and then don't really feel to
track the casual gamers that really but
until we do two really bad marketing
they thought it was just a weed with a
gamepad or a HD we they didn't realize
that was a new console it's just mainly
due to the confusing naming scheme and
the bad marketing and the core gamers
had already left Nintendo with the
launch of the week over to the Xbox 360
and ps2 me so at this point into Noah's
competing with Microsoft and Sony for
the
or gamers which obviously wasn't gonna
go very well
so clearly Nintendo did not do well with
presenting that we you there's a lot of
trash talk about the Wii U but let me
just say something about that with you
it's really not that bad of a console
yes it takes forever to turn on it's not
as powerful as the Xbox one or ps4 but
the Nintendo games for the Wii U were
actually really great and most of them
very successful switch games were
actually ports from the Wii U dad Mario
Kart 8 super smashing HD Super Mario 3d
World
Bayonetta 2 and splatoon and much much
more
they had outstanding first party games
and it looked fabulous on 1080p screens
most people didn't even have 4k screens
so it doesn't make a difference
people say the Nintendo Wii U field
because they had less storage and it was
underpowered but that's really not the
reason because a Nintendo switch is also
underpowered and does not have storage
for the main problem for the Wii U was
that it was marketed really badly it was
marketed towards the hardcore gamers who
had already left and gone through a ps4
and Xbox one and asked for the casual
gamers most of them didn't even know
what it was and had gone on to mobile
gaming so antenna was tucked in a very
weird place and chasing a demographic
that didn't even exist they were chasing
after hardcore gamers who are ok with
underpowered devices just so they can
play Nintendo games but they should have
been going after a casual gamer could
buy a Nintendo console to play Nintendo
games and a few third-party games here
and there and a combination for all of
these missteps led to very disappointing
sales of 13 million units and during
this time the 3ds XL and 2d s were also
released but those are nothing really
big and it did alright and this left
Nintendo in the worst position that they
have been in since the late 1990s and
Nintendo was stuffing this abyss until
July of 2016 when they launched the
Pokemon go this excuse me Tendo to
casual gamers once again and soon enough
the announced Nintendo switch which was
once again seen a lot yep
our core gamers are looking for
something much more powerful in they
didn't like when Nintendo was going and
this seemed to be like a repeat of the
Wii U it again didn't have that much
storage
it was very underpowered compared to the
ps4 and Xbox one but it was target at
the casual gamer which is the right move
for Nintendo it's a good thing that they
didn't targeted at the hardware gamers
because there's a lot of competition
there and the console market for
hardcore gamers is actually kind of
dying out especially as PC gaming has
become more affordable with the launch
of wiesen that bought high cars for low
prices anyways in the description a
clear purpose which was to play great
first party games any work with anyone
at any time and it made sure to fix all
the mistakes they made with the Wii U
sure they still have some small stores
but this was targeted at the casual
gamer who wasn't going to be going down
down like one or gigabyte plus games
sure was to honor power but that's
really all to meet women Tendo games and
had clear them floors joy columns and
the pro controller and the price of $300
was actually acceptable as it served two
purposes which is a home console and a
handheld gaming device it was more close
to being a revolutionary idea but it was
pulled off perfectly and it's a seamless
transitions between the two modes in the
loading times are outstanding it was a
three on a flat pad not turning on a
console and this made it really modern
it was looking crazy
it was simple easy to use and Walker
prep late with outstanding games and
that's really all you need and today
they have over 35 million sales globally
and their stock price has made a great
bounce back and while it is not as high
as before it is on the right track and
with the Nintendo swish it really looks
like Nintendo found their perfect niche
which is to offer great first party
games in a simple straightforward
console and the fact that can work as a
portable gaming device and a honk also
just makes it even better and the market
has responded well so Nintendo is
definitely on the right track for a lot
of us in Tendo is a very nostalgic
company that's played in Cornwall and
Maria for childhood entertainment
recently they made a couple of
steps and launched a Wii U which really
brought down a company and cost three
years of negative operating profits but
since then they're really correct our
mistakes and have come out on top with
the Nintendo switch and right now it
definitely seemed like the switch
allowed maintainer come back and today
they're here to stay but that's all I
have for you guys in in Tendo
make sure comment down below what
company you would like me to cover next
also if you like video the next drop
alive and consider subscribing if you'd
like to see more videos just like this
one
well then I'm Hari I'll see you guys
unnatural